學習的本質不是輸入
是便宜
就學立和學習是兩回事
就學立、證書都是給別人看的
通常是大功的使用的
就我們很久對學習的理解都是錯的
就他們怎麼學習呢 看書
報告吧 等老師學
我們下個什麼學習軟件啊
什麼聽說軟件啊
看來個好文章說長呢
這些都叫輸入
學習是什麼 學習是
你的就系統在生活和工作中
對於都問題的時候你要做的事
我再加著信法裡面
講過這麼一段話
但是認真聽一下
我就特別幫助
就是如果你對這個事的理解
是對的你的口袋裡
應該有你小的東西
否則的話
你就停在想想到底是哪裡
除了問題
我把它稱之為支持鬼打槍
什麼意思 是你的系統除了問題
不是不努力的問題
很像很努力啊
比如說克達
比如說諾泉氣啊
它不努力嗎 特別的努力
但是它的系統沒換
所以你的努力是沒有用的
我們很多人也一樣
就是我們從小的時候
我們有一套系統
最好系統可能是學校給你證的
家人給你證的
生活工作給你證的
我們理解這個世界都是根據
我們既有的系統說得也這個世界的
所以很多和這個系統
不一樣的東西
它會被排除在外
所有你的系統就一直沒變過
你的人生就很難發生外面
因為一直困在那個系統
而通常你的那個系統有的時候的版本
太低了
我給大家舉個例子啊
比如說我剛來短視評的時候
真的我看到好多人不知道該怎麼賺錢
我是從海的出生
所以我也是從怕了
所以我一直想怎麼這麼能賺錢
我一直希望有人直到我
沒有人
所以我完全怕自己沒說
等我摸著明白了以後
我發現很多人和我遇到的同樣的問題
所以我一上來跟大家分享怎麼賺錢的時候
現在好了
如果通過六年的方式
六年證明了
我不是可久才的
但是那個時候下面過的評論都是什麼
教你賺錢的人都是想賺錢
我知道那個時候騙人的人特別多
那種連到特別多
各久才特別多
所以他們就會形成一種
防禦這種防禦有什麼呢
教你賺的人全是想賺錢
雲是他就用這樣的一個認知
要的系統去看外面的事情
所以他可能看不到我的事情
當然我不算什麼
他可能看不到哪萬人的事情
那萬人說看不到
各位有沒有的說
看不到什麼
他把它的東西看不到
定不廢的東西
所以他會永遠用以前
難得去看這個事情
而你小的時候
你周邊沒有人教你這麼賺錢
學校也好
不告訴你這麼賺錢
你自己也沒有從來沒有研究過賺錢
你怎麼發生改變呢
你所有學生的東西
都是你原來的系統告訴你感覺的
你學的東西都是在加強以前的系統
你的系統會變得越來越高
你會被他死在以前的系統裡面
你根本就不會發生改變
這個好好體會的語話
學習的本質
不是輸入學習的本質是什麼
是變異
但你被封死在此的系統裡面
怎麼做呢
交給大家三個方法
第一個方法
就每天不幸就沒過一段時間
你們的自己
我今天或者我最近做的那些事
發現我過去的判斷
或者是我過去的行為是錯的
如果你好常時間都沒有發現
那幫我可以說
你好常的時間都在原有的系統裡面
沒有進步
第一個件事情
第二個事情的話
就是你要強制讓自己的時候
什麼意思
就是你列出幾個
你過去股定的是比如說
交你專家人都是想賺錢
或者是你要好好學習
考上好大學你的生活就幸福了
對吧
然後去找幾個法理
有沒有人是真的可以交到這個
這個專家的方法是有用的
有沒有人不是通過考大學
賺到錢的
是找一些法理
當你發現很多這種法理的時候
你就會發現你以前的系統有路路
你需要忽悉一套系統
至少對你以前的系統經營升級
這是第二套吧
第三套吧
無論你是看書也好還是看文章也好還是看視頻
看完了以後不要有那種
我會了我懂了我學到了
不要用我學到了這種感受
一定是這個樣子的
通過這條視頻或者這篇文章或者這個直播
我對某個概念有重新的理解
我發現
我應該有一些改變了
或者重新的理解的某個概念
所以看我基本直播的看了這條視頻
你可以在評論去留言說
我有重新的理解的某個概念
我對某一個事情的認識
有了一個新的認識
如果你寫不出來
說明你這條視頻
這條內容沒有給你帶來任何價值